alors vous avez vos peut tout pancarte
est ce aussi divisée que le premier
débat et on va laisser la parole à
alexian qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mais moi j'en peux plus j'allume cf1 ya
les copines d'arthur qui font toutes les
émissions d'arthur
pékin express on va pas me faire croire
que valérie trierweiler elle a dormi par
terre chez les habitants j'ai un peu
plus en fait moi de l'époque qui me
manque le plus c'est l'époque où j'ai
allumé les jeux télé par exemple je sais
pas le juste prix ou des choses comme ça
et on avait des anonymes et on
découvrait des gens l'impressionnant
parcours du rsa et puis on voit très
bien la dernière saison de koh lanta
elle est nullissime et il ya eu des
tricheries partout parce que les mecs
qui savent comment ça marche ils savent
comment ça fonctionne et franchement si
y'en a marre de ces émissions comme pour
puisqu'on parle de koh lanta l'émission
en 2018 s'appelait le combat des héros
et faisait revenir donc les candidats
emblématiques de koh lanta donc des
claude et laurent qu'on connaît et les
l'édition de 2018 a légèrement moins
bien marché que les éditions qui font
appel à des candidats donc anonyme mais
les cônes et d'anonymes il y en a encore
plein regarde tous les jeudis midi les
jeux au quotidien les 12 coups de midi à
tout le monde au point sa place ce sont
des candidats lambda ce qu'il faut faire
avec les stars et les émissions dénécé
les raréfier les événementiels ise
pourquoi parce que c'est en tout cas
pour eux hyper important pour faire de
la presse pour relancer un programme
c'est le cas de pékin express qui est un
peu en baisse vers fonds l'édition bip
pour relancer un petit peu la machine et
concernant of the boys ou encore koh
lanta qui représente comme la moitié des
divertissements de l'offre de
divertissement sur tf1 regarde c'est
essentiellement des anonymes qui sont
ils sont mises en avant qui est
finalement exactement la prochaine
saison de pékin express il y aura donc
inès règles johan riou valérie
trierweiler rachel legrain-trapani ex
miss france just ryad où théo currin au
casting est ce que ça vous donne envie
de regarder cette émission met alors à
en fait moi ce que je pense de toute
façon c'est que de tout temps il ya eu
le culte des héros en fait on est dans
une société en fin de tout temps on a
toujours eu besoin de héros et de
s'identifier à des héros je parle de koh
lanta parce que c'est la seule émission
que vraiment je connais en tant que
belge
et on a on a besoin en fait d'avoir
comme ça des machines de guerre qui nous
impressionne après c'est sûr que pour
les autres émissions avec les stars un
peu people etc ouais c'est ça parce
qu'en fait on nous promet des stars mais
moi ce que j'appelle une star c'est un
jean dujardin c'est un homard si c'est
pas des gens que j'ai vu une fois sur
tik tok à la limite sur les réseaux
sociaux mais ça c'est pas des stars
c'est des vedettes moi quand on me dit
des stars désolé mais là vous en
connaissez certains
moi aussi mais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que alors probablement ça
doit faire vendre ça va faire de
l'audience j'imagine parce que
maintenant dans fort boyard ya que des
dvd vedette d'ailleurs depuis depuis 30
ans des vedettes c'est plus les anime et
je pense que c'est c'est les gens en
fait en une forme de voyeurisme l' envie
de voir les stars dans des situations un
peu complexe c'est à dire voilà dans des
épreuves pékin express trouve que c'est
pas mal moi pourquoi pas je regarderai
pourquoi pas trahi leur valeur dans et
j'avais envie de vous montrer quand même
cette vidéo sur laëtitia milot je sais
pas si vous étiez au courant moi non je
l'aï appris en faisant cette émission
donc laetitia milot star incontournable
de plus belle la vie qui aujourd'hui
fait des fictions à succès sur tf1 eh
bien figurez-vous qu'elle a commencé la
télévision dans une téléréalité qui
s'appelait opération séduction
voici qu emilie elle a 21 ans et elle
est comédienne
elle a été choisie par la production
pour joue un rôle très important au sein
de l' aventure et va être présenté aux
candidats et aux jurys des parents comme
une nouvelle candidate à part entière
séductrice manipulatrice elle n'aura
aucune limite pour plaire aux garçons je
pense que
déjà utilisé le charme le corps la façon
dont j'ai la façon d'en parler les
petites villes et déterminante appelés
au salut
ce à quoi tous les chemins mènent à rome
mais aussi ariane brodier qui a été qui
a émergé grâce à cet investissement
je crois que c'est opter opération
séduction
mairie
exact bachelot alors comment ces vilains
michel de tout ça est ce que les stars à
la télé ça fait marcher mieux les
émissions moi c'est les concepts me
lasser mais le fait que ça soit des
héros enfin des gens qu'on connaisse
déjà au chaud qu'on gagne un temps fou
ce que moi venus est gris moi ce que
j'aime c'est des tests et des gens dont
il parle vite passé les épisodes savoir
qui je veux pas pouvoir sac et si je
sais de troubler la quelle sera ma tête
de turc préférée on gagne du temps si
vous la connaissez déjà un peu ça vous
rassure vous rassure je sais que je vais
pas pouvoir saccadé le petit ali moi je
trouve que ça redynamise le programme
j'adore moi retrouver des gens que je
connais justement une ancienne première
dame de france dans une émission comme
pékin express est d'ailleurs en plus de
ça ces émissions seront pas oubliés
aussi qu'elle donne beaucoup à des
associations par exemple le fort boyard
depuis dix ans en 1991 a donné pour plus
de 200 associations donc heureusement
quand même qu'il y à ça parce que ça
permet de redynamiser et de donner de la
visibilité aux associations et j'avoue
moi le voyeurisme je suis très fan
j'adore ça regarde et noir dans des
situations compliquées l'insecte aimant
et puis allez maintenant sardinade
l'après f1 moyart il avait testé la
version anonyme dans les années 2000
sont inhalées par l'itu marché une
saison ils ont remis les célébrités et
c'est reparti à vraiment sentir la fibre
la sensibilité par exemple rendez vous
en terre inconnue
j'adore le concept pascal côté voyage
c'est magnifique mais moi j'adore des
cons avec un anonyme ça marcherait pas
du tout c'est un inconnu
[Applaudissements]
soit le sujet son élection qui en a
marre dollars mais moi j'en peux plus
parce que si ce serait la première fois
qu'on les verrait je suis d'accord mais
quand sa fille font les dix émissions de
tf1 ils font distribuer dans les boîtes
d'un bêta pour les voies d'un les
touristes rue au bout d'un moment voir
toujours les mêmes têtes alors là oui
pékin express à la limite valérie
trierweiler souci pevensie cévennes
maintiennent mais quand ça fait 10 fois
qu'on voit les mêmes personne n'a les
mêmes émissions moi je suis désolé mais
j'en peux plus et les audiences sont
bonnes mais ça dépend des émissions il
ya certaines émissions ou même si à des
célébrités ça c'est forcément un bon
exemple ggd des nouveautés notables de
ces quatre dernières années les
dernières années qui a émergé ces masses
singer typiquement c'est un vrai succès
et l'intérieur il ya des célébrités oui
c'est forcément un jeu wii des
célébrités sur moi le sortez moi le
gagnant de la première saison sheila
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
défini vous même comme un aigri
mais par exemple le concept de la
famille en or qui est donc un jeu
télévisé très très établis en france
qu'on adore tous pourquoi cette version
célébrités ce que c'est utile maxime
vous pensez à la version célébrités
seulement étaient programmées en prime
time le reste avec des anonymes c'était
en deuxième partie de soirée donc oui
effectivement c'est à petit ça attire
les gens après faut oublier faut pas
oublier que la famille en or c'était au
départ un programme de prêts access mais
aussi de matinée donc voilà il faut
faire évoluer en fonction de la casse et
programmation moi j'aime bien quand ça
mail les deux en fait quand on est par
exemple tir ami denis avermes anonyme
est une célébrité romy de la croisette
c'était des 70 il ya tout le monde a son
mot à dire qui est produit par bob
berridge est entre autres sur france 2
août à une célébrité et triggiano burger
quiz aussi par exemple c'était moi
j'aimais bien quand justement il y avait
les deux les lynx dérange c'est quand
même vachement géniaux
fenêtre quand ils prennent encore ermani
encore une émission un autre concept
c'est la téléralité avec les nouilles
moi ce que j'appelle les new inouïe
c'est à dire oui en fallait aller un peu
les débilos on va dire où ils recyclent
à chaque fois donc là on a le mariage
des débiles hausse
on a les noms mais ça n'engage que moi
moi personnellement ça m'intéresse et ça
cartonne certains sur ça marche très
bien justement ça marche en partie parce
que les gens s'attachent aux personnages
je suis ctpm pc de saudi bus exact de
copains se dit comme ça mais je préfère
les kardashian tu vas qu'on s'a après
chacun ses délires chaque artisan burns
on peut préférer les marseillais où
l'écart la chance ça reste un peu du
pareil au mas c'est pas pareil oui bon
ah non elle joue maintenant elles ont
monté un empire colossal excédent
retouche photo maintenant j'attends
disait surtout quelle belle remontée ce
temps pire c'est que c'est la mer la mer
c'est de la télé réalité avec exactement
les mêmes personnages et que les
téléspectateurs s'attache à voir les
personnages évoluent et oui au fil des
saisons